by the way youtube is now blatantly
lying they responded to me because you
know they won't respond to us on twitter
unless we unless mr medicare retweets us
yeah yeah what's going on with that i
don't i i'm gonna i'm pulling out that
up next uh the whole medicare thing that
happened with his account oh let's play
his video first then and then i can give
you guys
um here let me
give me a second i know you sent it to
me here it is
uh the video is called grab your ankles
from mr medicare let's play this and
then and
we could of course relate to this
because this happened to us how many
months ago is it now how great would it
be if mr medicare copyright struck us
hilarious everybody could play my stuff
except those two
[Laughter]
so youtube actually a new email from
youtube
what no everybody told me they don't
care about the little guy
maybe they're writing me to tell me what
a good boy i am only good news ahead
click on this right away it should bring
my family in so they can read it with me
sure it's some kind of an announcement
maybe they're going to enshrine my
youtube channel for following the rules
so well
hi mr medicare oh my god so formal they
even called me mister
during a recent review our team of
policy specialists
carefully looked over the videos you've
uploaded to your channel
and we found that a significant portion
of your channel is not in line with our
partnership program
as of today your channel is not eligible
to monetize and you will not have access
to monetization tools and features
please go to your monetization page to
read more about the specific policy our
specialists flagged
well this is difficult news to swallow
but if their specialist hand
flagged these videos they must have had
a reason i'm sure
i'm sure it's tough news but i gotta
roll with the punches let's go find out
exactly what the
violation was so i can learn from it to
become a better content producer on this
amazing platform account status
currently ineligible for monetization
here's why your channel wasn't approved
reused content repurposing someone
else's content without adding
significant original commentary
or educational value doesn't it doesn't
he take
didn't he take down all his videos and
take down all his streams he streams it
and he immediately deletes it by the way
it doesn't private them deletes them
so this is actually beautiful because uh
i just found out today as well
um it's not just medicare they're going
after a lot of people gator
uh yeah i saw this to do the kill stream
i don't know if he still does the kill
stream i know they were kind of
hot and cold for a while there but uh
gator his channel got hit as well
and um everybody's getting this reused
content
but medicare is in the perfect position
to [ __ ] these guys now because he
literally has no videos
yeah he has no let's finish planes can
reapply
in 30 days on december 4th 2019.
that's a lot of pressure i've got a
whole 30 days to go through my
enormous catalog of videos to see if i
can reapply for
monetization it's going to be tough it's
going to be arduous
but it's a task i'm up to i'm going to
look through all my videos
to see which ones that weren't compliant
with this specialist that works for
youtube
they must have seen something i
overlooked where can i begin my journey
i know i should go look at my uploaded
videos and just start going through them
one by one oh wait a minute
i don't have any [ __ ] uploaded videos
there's
zero videos on my channel but that can't
be right clearly the specialist knows
better than i do
i don't i don't understand what's going
on here oh that's right
back in august when i had some videos
taken down for [ __ ] reasons
and decided to delete my entire video
archive
on youtube that's why there are no
videos currently available on the
channel
you can even find the specific date that
those videos were removed
based on the patreon post that i put up
going over the details of it
or through the metrics available over on
socialblade and those aren't
privated videos they're deleted videos
as in there's nothing on the channel no
unlisted video no private video just
nothing
not zero well it seems i've got a bit of
a
a conundrum here a youtube specialist
flagged my videos saying that i was
reusing other people's content
and yet there are no videos so there
couldn't possibly be
reused content to begin with i think
this is what's referred to as a sphinx
riddle
if i can solve it i'll probably gain
immortality really
medicare is hilarious man that's very
funny he's always been one of my
favorite [ __ ]
god damn making me think here reusing
content and videos but there are no
videos to reuse the content in the
chicken or the egg which came first i
don't
i don't know how to answer that stranger
still that email was dated from
yesterday just a day ago that the
youtube specialist decided to look at my
amazing archive of zero videos when all
the channels videos were
removed and deleted nine weeks ago
maybe this youtube specialist got his
job because doc brown recommended him i
didn't know marty mcfuckin fly worked at
google but
there he is we got the answer to that
vh1 question where are they now
apparently working at youtube
at least nothing bad happened i mean i
never played ads on my video so it's not
like that monetization came in handy
it's not like
i had super chats coming oh wait the
super chats
well youtube's a trustworthy and
reputable company
look at that last payment from the
previous month's livestream
oh what's what's that tweet say oh it
seems the exact opposite of what i
thought is true
that when your channel is demonetized
and you're thrown out of the partnership
program
they just they just keep the money it
just it sits in a bank account
accruing yeah and then maybe if you
somehow ever get
remonetized if you're ever allowed back
into the partnership program
maybe then potentially two months or
two billing cycles from that point maybe
you get paid
in the meantime all that sweet interest
that's all google baby god i suppose if
you were a cynical sort of person you
could say there was a
vested financial interest in
demonetizing people that have
received super chats because the
interest accrues on the account held by
google
but that's alex jones talk okay
you bring that over to infowars not over
here all right this is youtube
it's family-friendly neighborhood okay
we only want to see videos of elsa and
spider-man
injecting each other with shit-filled
syringes i'm talking quality
entertainment the stuff coca-cola and
nissan want to advertise on so what's
the status of jimmy's channel now well
i upload over on bit shoot feel free to
look at new videos
as they get released over there i've
actually put up three new videos over on
bit shoot it's for the majority of new
content's going
they're not so authoritarian with their
terms of service on what you can and
cannot make fun of
as for live streaming i can't still
technically live stream over here
just can't get that money doing it i
don't know i'm gonna have to sell a [ __ ]
ton of hats to make up for that by the
way
buy my hat see this is how it works i'm
really [ __ ] sad right now
youtube stole my money so the only way
to get me out of my deep deep depression
over all that sweet sweet youtube
dollar-y dudes you gotta buy a [ __ ]
hat or you can subscribe to patreon
either works
as for my plans about how i'm gonna move
forward with that demonetization thing
and that super chat money that's just
sitting in limbo
well you're gonna pay what you [ __ ]
owe susan i'm gonna get my money if i
have to upload videos of stick figures
playing chess while i read the daily
weather report
i'm gonna [ __ ] do it where the money
at susan
so we know about this we know we know
we know all too well about
six months ago let's say six months ago
maybe a little more than about six
months ago our channel was monetized and
we had no problems and no issues and
then after whenever the crowder
carlos mazza thing happened the the the
crowder carlos massa avad
vox apocalypse part two or whatever uh
they demonetized a lot of channels of
sinatra for example got demonetized uh
night both night waves got demonetized
um
rotc revenge of the sisters very channel
got demonetized
and um you know obviously we we appealed
it
they said we could re we apply for
monetization they said that we didn't
meet the standards of blah blah blah
blah blah
some typical [ __ ] line however
they owed revenge of the cis 3
300 yeah 3 300. they owed
night wave how much 12 between around
between
1300
of those about 4 500 a significant
amount of money to us
of course yes uh and
we thought we figured okay well you know
what fine we're not monetized
we can't take we can't take uh super
chats anymore we'll just do stream laps
it's fine we were pissed obviously we
said it was [ __ ] up
but we figured well they got to pay us
the money they owed us because they did
run amazon our video they did they ran
ads on our video and
we received super chat everyone got paid
except for us yes
everybody got their money except for us
so what happened is the pay cycle came
and went
and we didn't get any money we try to
contact them we've been trying to
contact them we've been trying to
contact them for six months
they ignored us i tried to email them
they ignored us
mike tried to email them they ignored us
we tried to tweet them directly
they ignored us mike tried to tweet them
directly they ignored us
they ignored us they ignored us and they
they they still to this day
it's now been more than six months have
our money
they're holding on to our money and
there's no plan to ever give us
the money nope not at all and this is
what they have been
doing routinely um i'm i mean
you know it sucks this happened to
medicare but it's also
maybe it'll shine some light on it you
know as to what's really
what's happening yeah i mean we the
bottom line is nothing was going to get
done but now
something might get done because i mean
unfortunately
they have to [ __ ] somebody as big as
medicare before it
you know before anybody really notices
it so
so you said they tweeted back what what
happened you said uh yeah
so you know medicare was tweeting about
it so
team youtube responded to medicare and i
took that opportunity to jump down their
throat while i could
right so i said why did you keep twelve
hundred dollars for me and thirty three
hundred dollars from rotc radio you
can't just not pay people money you owe
them you demonetized us months ago
you refuse to remonetize us and you
won't pay us the money you owe us
this is illegal they wrote back thanks
for the tag
any revenue earned prior to being
removed from the youtube partner program
will still be paid out through your
adsense account
based on the standard payment thresholds
and timeline well hang on
if you're below 100 you can close your
adsense account here's how
so i literally just retw i
screenshotted that i tweeted it i tagged
them again i said
uh this is an example of at team youtube
straight up lying they will not pay you
the balance of the monies owed after
you're demonetized
they disconnect your youtube partner
account from your adsense correct and
the money just gets held forever
they are stealing from us and collecting
interest and then i
um followed up i added to that tweet and
wrote
this statement on twitter by team
youtube is in direct contrast
to the real answer that they give
content creators in private via email
and then i shared the sinatra
uh tweet email where he just says all
earnings you accrued before your channel
was demonetized
will remain and will only be transferred
to adsense again
once your reapplication to the youtube
partner program
is approved this is illegal this is
illegal
i don't give any private company terms
of i don't give a [ __ ] what your terms
of service says
this is illegal this is theft
and depending on how many people they've
done this to and how long it's been
going on
this is legitimately like grand theft
so they they they are saying something
completely different that they're
telling other people here's what's
happening
if i remember correctly when i spoke to
i spoke to ethan ethan ralph i spoke to
him about the demonetization he goes
they eventually gave me the money
after he reapplied for monetization and
they said no a second time
once they delete it but they're not
they're not processing our applications
exactly but nightwave the backup channel
never got monetized
it never got demonetized never got
monetized i applied
right after the main one got monetized
and that was
almost a year ago and they have not they
refuse
to monetize they're purposely ignoring
these applications and stretching it out
so they can steal your money
and my sunshine like len
i'll quit right now what
steal my sunshine bro uh so yeah they
have our
they they have our money they've had our
money and you're right they've been
sitting on our because i
as soon as because they said in 30 days
you could reapply for monetization
exactly 30 days i reapplied for
monetization
it has now been six months and they've
ignored it they've ignored it and and
like medical pointed out and we've
pointed out many many times
they're getting interest on this money
they're making money off of this and
they're not paying anybody out and
before anybody goes
follow the lawsuit sure
yeah we'll sue alphabet inc yeah they
won't run
they won't run out the clock in court
make us go bankrupt
so i mean you know i'm i'm hoping i'm
hoping that the medicare stuff actually
shines some light on they're just lying
about yeah they straight up light i'm
reading out what they said you they
straight up lie to you
they straight up just lie to you it'll
be paid out
no it's not it's not being paid out
because what you're if what you're
saying is true
then we'd already have our money and we
don't
we don't have our money um and we're
still waiting for them to approve
we're still waiting for them to approve
or disappro because that's why i applied
i
applied not reapplied not thinking oh
they're gonna monetize us that's
you know i figured they're gonna say no
but once they tell you no the second
time
okay cool then you're just gonna pay me
right and yes
you know obviously we our show is not
huge we're a smaller show and that's a
good chunk of money for us
but it's not even about the money it's
about the fact that they're stealing
that money
part of that money a big chunk of that
money was super chats was money that
fans
gave to us yeah that they took 30
percent of
yeah but now they're keeping 100 that
money is
they've already run ads on our they ran
ads on our videos
they they charged gm and they charged
all these companies they were going to
run your ads on all these stuff
they got all the money we didn't because
they
don't [ __ ] care and
again when you're a smaller channel they
don't
give a [ __ ] and they're not going
to give a [ __ ]
uh yeah i know i know and it's really
fun i mean
medicare didn't even have any videos up
so what are they getting him for
because of who he is of course it's
because of who it's all it is it's just
that
they're not looked these are
[ __ ] made-up arbitrary rules they
don't actually care about any of the
rules they just need enough rules that
they can nail whoever they want on them
and not nail other people on them
it's [ __ ] and i just want my [ __ ]
money
and um i don't think that we're i still
don't think that we're gonna get it
i still and you know it's it's it's it's
all it's also funny that how many times
have you tweeted at team youtube and
they didn't reply
they only replied when it get when
they're getting heat when they're
getting heat when it when medicare
tweets it and everybody starts
responding then they're like
we have to pay attention to this one now
uh i don't
i don't think they're going i don't
think anything's gonna happen i really
don't think they care
and there's nothing you're going to do
that's what happened and that's millions
of dollars they're not paying out and
they're collecting interest
that is correct millions of dollars not
just a couple people a lot of people got
to monetize it's tens of thousands of
creators so you figure even if it's
small amounts it's it's
it's a lot you know